Drei Spieltage sind gespielt bei manchen Vereinen, brennt schon wieder der sprichwörtliche Baum. Anderswo könnte die Laune kaum besser sein. Wir wollen drüber sprechen. Und das mache ich jetzt mit Michi Fischer vom Fürther Flachpass und den Nürnberger Nachrichten und Lisa Höfer von der Sportschau. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rosti ist zu kurz ab, der lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja und damit Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zurück zur Ligatour, zur 2. Liga der Männer. Ich bin Eva-Lotta Bohle und vor 3 Wochen saß ich zuletzt hier mit Marc. Und wir haben ja nach dem ersten Spieltag ein wenig auf die kommende Saison geblickt, ein bisschen Prognosen abgegeben. Mir wurde zugetragen, wir sollen heute bitte nicht über die Tabellentipps sprechen. Sämtliche Menschen sind etwas enttäuscht, sagen wir mal so, nach 3 Spieltagen. Aber es sind jetzt 3 Pflichtspiele mit dem Pokal 4 ins Land gezogen. Und wir wollen neben der Lage der Liga auf die Situation bei einigen Vereinen blicken. Aber noch mal zur Erinnerung, natürlich nicht so detailliert, wie ihr das aus der letzten Saison kennt. Also hier geht es jetzt nicht 90 Minuten lang nur um Fürth und Nürnberg. Wir haben das allererste Frankendorfer hier schon mal an Land gezogen. Aber Spaß zur Seite, ich muss zum Glück jetzt nicht alleine über die Teams sprechen, sondern ich darf die ersten beiden Mitglieder des neu gegründeten Rasenfunk Ligatour, 2. Liga All-Star-Teams begrüßen. Und zum einen freue ich mich sehr, dass Lisa Höfer mal wieder bei uns ist. Sie ist Redakteurin bei der Sportschau und hat sich passenderweise für uns Zeit genommen. Hallo Lisa.
Ja, ich glaube einfach, weil, also man muss einfach sagen, solche Hypes ziehen einfach Leute an, die man vielleicht auch einfach, also, die dann auf einmal alle da sind. Ich habe es dir in der ersten Folge angesprochen, was halt momentan dahinter steckt, hinter diesem Hype. Ich check auch, wenn das irgendwann allen anderen Fans auf den Keks geht, muss ich auch ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich glaube, also, ich finde diese Diskussion, wer leidet am meisten, sowieso immer so ein bisschen schwachsinnig, weil es ist einfach subjektiv. Ich verstehe jeden Club-Fan, der sagt, wir haben die meiste Scheiße ehrlich gesagt mitgenommen. Frag mal bei MSV Duisburg oder 1860 München nach. Also, das ist halt sowieso subjektiv. Ja, ich glaube, ich bin ganz froh, dass es jetzt passiert ist mit der Niederlage. Dann hat man eben auch die Chance, das jetzt ganz gut einzuordnen. Und es geht jetzt eben am Samstag gegen Eintracht Braunschweig weiter. Aber generell macht es trotzdem Spaß, Bielefeld-Fans zu sein. Aber ganz liebe Grüße an die Leute, die dann direkt nach dem Gegentor gestern das Stadion verlassen hat. Das Spiel dauert so lange, bis der Schiedsrichter abfreut.
Okay, das ist natürlich lost.
Ja, und über die Schiedsrichterleistung habe ich noch ehrlich gesagt gar keinen Bock mehr zu diskutieren. Ich sage nur noch mal, wenn so ein VAR-Check drei Minuten dauert und dann ist nicht so ganz klar, was der Schiedsrichter mit seiner Geste meint, das werden wir dann ja bald geklärt haben. Auch das Flächen, beziehungsweise auch in der 2. Liga überall, glaube ich jetzt, auch die, ich glaube, nach der Länderspielpause die Stadion ansagen, bei allen 2. Ligisten starten, wenn ich da richtig informiert bin. Aber gut, zu viel dazu. Genau Bielefeld jetzt eben gegen Braunschweig und dann nach der Länderspielpause. Da brauche ich, glaube ich, sogar keinen Zettel, um das rauszufinden. Geht es erst gegen Magdeburg am Freitagabend und dann kommt die Spielvereinigung und führt auf die Alm. Ein Spiel, das ich leider verpassen werde. Das tut mir sehr leid.
Ich nicht. Ob es mir dann leid tut, werde ich danach sehen. Aber ich werde da sein. Schauen wir mal. Ist auch wieder klar. Dann werde ich einmal nach Bielefeld kommen in 4 Jahren. Dann bist du dich da, Eva.
Das ist natürlich auch der größte Zufall. Ja, ja. Alles mit Absicht. Eine ganz kleine Sache. Ich wollte eigentlich hier, da habe ich mich selber versprochen, und zwar wollte ich so ein bisschen Sachen neben dem Platz hier noch einbringen. Einmal bei Bielefeld einfach, weil ich weiß, da gibt es ein bisschen Diskussionen, weil der Stadionsprecher der Bielefelder Damen ja durchaus aufgefallen ist wegen, ja, sagen wir mal, AfD nahen Äußerungen und eben auch social media technisch. Und da muss man sagen, ist es manchmal vielleicht auch ein Nachteil, dass es jetzt eben diesen Hype gibt, weil sowas vielleicht dann manchmal ein bisschen untergeht. Aber da kann man schon sicher sein, das wird von den Fans auch ganz gut angesprochen, dass eben das nicht weitergeht. Aber man muss da leider einfach sagen, da ist eben auch der Fußball der Frauen. Gerade dann, wenn es da eben nur Regionalliga, also 3. Liga ist, dann tatsächlich, weil eben viel auf ehrenamtlicher Basis passiert, ja, geht dann immer so ein bisschen unter, leider. Aber so viel dazu noch. Gut. Dann lass uns auf zwei Teams gucken, die bei ganz, ganz vielen tatsächlich als Abstiegskandidaten gelten oder gegolten haben. Und das sind Braunschweig und Elversberg. Und da muss man sagen, die beide mit einem guten Start in die Saison. Also Braunschweig, also beide sechs Punkte. Und dazu muss man sagen, wenn ich richtig nachgeguckt hatte, hat Eintrott Braunschweig sechs Punkte letztes Jahr erst nach dem Derbysieg gegen Hannover im Oktober 2024. Nee, doch 2024 gehabt. Wow. Es ist Montag. Naja, morgen. Genau. Und generell, also Braunschweig, die hatten ja ein Wochenende mehr Pause, weil ihr Gegner, der VfB Stuttgart im DFB Pokal, den Supercup gespielt haben. Ich weiß, ich wiederhole mich da. Ich finde das ehrlich gesagt immer noch ein Unding, dass am Ende des Tages die unterklassigen Vereine darunter leiden müssen, in Anführungszeichen, und eben dann eine englische Woche haben. Ja, sehe ich irgendwie immer noch nicht so als ganz fair an, aber gut. Genau, Braunschweig jetzt eben in einer 2-0-Niederlage gegen Karlsruhe. Die haben das Spielfreie Wochenende genutzt, um nochmal so ein Mini-Trainingslager zu machen, was ein bisschen komisch klingt nach zwei Siegen und nach zwei Spieltagen. Aber da ging es, glaube ich, Heiner Backhaus vor allem um das Spiel mit dem Ball. Ja, war jetzt nicht so gut gegen Karlsruhe, kann man glaube ich sagen. Aber ich glaube, da, also in Braunschweig behält man da die Ruhe. Das war ja trotzdem auch alles gut soweit. Ja, also Michi, du hast ja Braunschweig auch gesehen. Er hebt schon hier die Hand. Was hast du zu Braunschweig zu sagen?
Ich habe Braunschweig gesehen, habe sie in den letzten Jahren noch öfter gesehen und fand sie das tatsächlich, das war ja vor zwei Wochen, drei Wochen, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, also auf jeden Fall vor einigen Tagen, erst, dass sie da tatsächlich besser aussahen insgesamt, als sie es in den letzten Jahren getan haben. Ich muss auch sagen, die haben da einfach auch ein paar ganz gute Transfers getätigt für das Spiel mit dem Ball Lino Tempelmann, Robin Heuser, das sah einfach gut aus. Sie haben dafür Rayan Philipp verloren, dafür war Erincani Adimci im Spiel gegen Fürth, fand ich gut. Also es hat offensiv schon besser ausgesehen. Weshalb ich aber immer noch ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen habe, also dieser Sieg gegen Fürth, da lagen sie auch erst mal hinten und dann haben sie mit zwei relativ schnellen Angriffen, bei der die Fürther Defensive, die ja gerade schon wieder die 2 schlechteste in der Liga ist, nicht gut aussah, da 2 Tore gemacht. Sie sind aber in der zweiten Halbzeit noch ganz schön geschwommen, haben dann für viel den Ball gegeben, eigentlich fast schon zu viel, finde ich dafür, dass man sich auch spielerisch verbessern will in einem Heimspiel. Sie haben das Spiel dann aber trotzdem spät in Ausgleich noch gewonnen mit einer Willensleistung. Da ist Heiner Backhaus natürlich dann sehr glücklich gewesen. Der hat schon vor dem Spiel sehr viel von Herz gesprochen und von, dass man immer alles geben muss. Ich kenne das auch aus Furt von dem Trainer. Wenn man immer von alles geben und sehr viel Herzblut und Gier und Leidenschaft und Kämpfe und so weiter spricht, irgendwann nutzt sich das ab. Ich bin gespannt, wann sich das abnutzt bei Braunschweig. Ich sehe bei ihnen weitaus weniger Schwarze als in der letzten Saison. Das ist aber auch nicht schwer. Das habt ihr auch in der Vorschau schon ein bisschen besprochen. Sie sind halt mit Acht und Krach irgendwie drin geblieben, was auch daran lag, dass der erste Zerbrückende in der Relegation auch nicht wirklich gut war in den Spielen. Man ist dann drin geblieben, das ist das Wichtigste.
Das hast du freundlich ausgedrückt.
Ja, ich bin ein freundlicher Mensch tendenziell. Da hat man schon darauf reagiert. Es gab ja auch schon diese Wutrede von Sven Köhler, der der neue Kapitän jetzt auch ist in Braunschweig. Nach dem Relegationsspiel, wenn man so weitermacht wie in der letzten Saison, dann wird man irgendwann absteigen. Hat offenbar nicht für so viel Freude im Umfeld des Vereins gesorgt. Ich habe auch ein bisschen den Podcast der Kollegen, ein bisschen Werbeblock, Studio Blau-Gelb, da kann man sich gerne mal anhören. Da waren Sven Köhler und Ron Torbenhoffmann bei einem Live-Podcast zu Gast auch sehr erfrischend. Köhler, neuer Kapitän, nachdem man Eisen-Ermin verabschiedet hat. Er war ein sehr wichtiger Spieler, Ermin Bicakčić in der letzten Saison. Da hat man auch den Umbruch gewagt mit einem neuen Trainer, Heiner Bakos, der ja in Aachen davor war. Man hat da viel versucht umzudrehen, dafür sind die sechs Punkte jetzt schon mal sehr gut. Aber ich bleibe dabei, dass das Eintracht-Branche trotzdem weit hinten mitspielen wird, weil der Kader individuell zwar besser ist als der letzte Saison, aber noch weit nicht so gut ist wie viele andere Mannschaften. Und ich auch vom Spiel mit dem Ball jetzt bislang nicht so überzeugt war von dem, was ich gesehen habe. Der erste Sieg gegen Magdeburg war ja auch glücklich. Da hat man dann mit einem Schuss aus 40 Metern, ich weiß nicht, ich habe die, ich habe sich abgemessen. Aber man hat da auf jeden Fall mit einem Fernschuss dann das 1-0 gemacht gegen Magdeburger, die jetzt auch im ersten Spiel keinen Titzahura-Fußball gespielt haben. Also das waren wichtige Punkte, die muss man holen. Die sechs Punkte hat man jetzt schon mal. Die helfen einem vielleicht am Ende, wenn es dann auf wenige Punkte ankommt. Aber ich würde mir das auch gerne, wie Lisa vorhin mal gesagt hat, bei Braunschweig auch noch ein paar Wochen anschauen, um dann ein abschließendes Urteil zu fällen. Aber sie haben jetzt schon mal die Punkte und dann kann man damit auch leichter arbeiten. Das ist schon mal sehr gut für alle Braunschweigerinnen und Braunschweiger.
Ja und ich finde trotz Einmalt auch einfach ein gutes Zeichen von Backhaus, dass man eben gesagt hat, ne auch noch zwei Spieltage nochmal als ein Fokus auf das Spiel mit dem Ball legen. Also das fand ich auch schon irgendwie, dass man da direkt sagt, ne wir erkennen unsere Probleme schon. Gut man muss auch gleichzeitig immer sagen, gut das habt ihr dann in der Vorbereitung gemacht. Also die ist dann ja auch nicht so lange. Ne aber, also generell bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt. Also morgen Abend, 20.45 Uhr, ja Montag logischerweise, wann ihr mir ja auch diesen Podcast hört, geht es dann eben gegen Stuttgart im Pokal. Und da bin ich schon, ja also ich bin schon gespannt. Also einfach auch nach diesem ersten Spiel der Stuttgarter, das mich doch durchaus, das könnt ihr natürlich alles in der Rasenfunk-Besprechung nachhören zu diesem ersten Spieltag. Bin ich schon gespannt, was eintragt, weil sie müssen ja den Ball in diesem Spiel einfach nicht haben. Also das ist ja schon mal klar, dass Stuttgart da eben das Spiel machen muss. Und da bin ich sehr gespannt, was wir da von Eintracht Braunschweig sehen.
Das war schon fast ein perfekter Werbeteaser, du morgen im Ersten natürlich oder in der ARD Mediathek, um natürlich auch meinem Auftrag nachzukommen. Ich bin gespannt, yes.
Nur als Vollständigkeit halber natürlich am Mittwoch dann das Spiel zwischen Bayern München und Wiesbaden. Am Mittwochabend in Wiesbaden.
Beide Kollegen im ZDF.
So, danke schön. Juhu an der Stelle. Lass uns noch kurz auf die SV Elbersberg gucken, weil ich würde sagen, die hat uns bisher auch ganz gut überrascht. Ich glaube, bei der waren sehr viele auch der Überzeugung. Ohne Horst Steffen und ohne die Spieler, die Elbersberg ausgemacht haben, wird das nix. Wir waren nach dem Sieg gegen Nürnberg noch ein wenig verhalten. Dann gab es eben diese durchaus unglückliche Niederlage gegen Bochum. Hatte aber sicherlich viel mit zu tun mit dem frühesten Platzverweis, glaube ich, zumindest in der 2. Liga, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe. Aber jetzt zum Beispiel gegen den FCK am Freitagabend. Zwar auch wieder ein Last-Minute-Tor, aber da muss man sagen hoch verdient. Die haben richtig, richtig guten Fußball über weite Strecken gegen Kaiserslautern gespielt. Man muss sagen, bisher ein interessanter Start von Elbersberg. Sie fliegen natürlich weiterhin so ein bisschen unterm Radar bzw. kommen, glaube ich, ganz gut klar mit dieser Underdog-Krolle, die sie trotz der guten letzten Saison fahren.
Ich glaube, da hast du schon was Totalbares gesagt an der Stelle. Die fühlen sich wohl damit, dass sie gerade nicht so gehypt sind, dass sie so ein bisschen unterm Radar fliegen, dass keiner so Erwartungen irgendwie hat, weil man eben weiß, okay, viele Spieler verloren, Trainer weg. Und das ist eher so eine, mal gucken, wie es wird dieses Jahr. Ich habe sie tatsächlich auch als Absteiger getippt, weil ich nicht so überzeugt war, ob man so einen großen Umbruch in dieser sehr, sehr engen Liga so auffangen kann. Der erste Spieltag gegen Nürnberg hatten wir ja gerade schon so ein bisschen angerissen. Da habe ich jetzt ehrlicherweise auch noch nicht so viel gesehen, dass ich sagen würde, naja, okay, die bleiben in der Liga und das könnte was werden. War aber halt auch wirklich der erste Spieltag. Deswegen bin ich total gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt. Jetzt am Freitag gegen Kaiserslautern habe ich gefühlt auch nur von Lautern-Fans, so aus meinem persönlichen Umfeld gehört, die frustriert waren, dass es nicht so lief, was so ein bisschen auch an der Leistung von Lautern selbst lag. Ich bin aber total gespannt und glaube, aus Elbersberger Sicht kann man einfach so froh sein, dass es so losging, wie es losging. Ich würde happy sein, dass man diese sechs Punkte jetzt schon im Sack hat und erst mal deutlich besser dasteht, als man das vielleicht auch selber so eingeschätzt hätte. Also wenn man so die ersten Spiele guckt, so gegen wen muss man ran, glaube ich macht sich ja schon immer so ein Gefühl breit, so ist das machbar oder wird es eher schwer. Und da hätte ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt aus Elbersberger Sicht getippt, dass man da mit sechs Punkten ehrlicherweise dasteht. Deswegen das wird für mich so ein Club ehrlicherweise, wo ich gespannt bin, ob das so weitergeht. Also hat mich positiv überrascht, zumindest mit Blick auf die Zähler, die man jetzt schon gesammelt hat.
Ich habe sie auch auf Platz 16 getippt, bilde ich mir ein. Aber das lag auch ein bisschen daran an den Transverse. Wenn man zu den ersten Spieltagen anschaut, ist es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr dieser aufregende Fußball mit Aslani und Co., der jeden Spieltag denkt, Wahnsinn, was die da abliefern. Aber es wirkt insgesamt sehr solide. Auch die Verbindungen sind wieder sehr klug. Ich finde immer noch Ole Burg, der Manager der Elvesberger, einen der besten der 2. Liga, auch immer noch sehr unterschätzt. Wenn andere Vereine nach Sportdirektoren oder Sportgeschäftsführern schauen, sollten sie auch mal in Saarland schauen, auch wenn es vielleicht ein weiter Weg ist dorthin. Aber der macht einfach seit Jahren extrem gute Arbeit. Auch das Trainer-Scouting, mit dem Vincent Wagner auch sehr aufwendig gescoutet. Vincent Wagner ist plötzlich auch ein anderer Mensch. Ich habe mich am Freitag bei SkyMet gewundert. Der Trainer bei Interviews war Vincent Wagner, der ja optisch jetzt ganz anders aussieht. Wer es nicht gesehen hat, schaut es euch an. Aber auch der Bamba Sekundär hat mir letztes Jahr schon sehr gut gefallen beim KSC. Er hat dann noch mal Schritte nach vorne gemacht, ist jetzt auch wieder gut gewesen im letzten Spiel. Amara Kondy ist auch solider Zweitligaspieler. Lukas Petkoff findet sich dort immer besser zurecht als Spieler. Schnellbacher ist immer noch da, hat eben wieder ein Tor gemacht. Das ist auch eine der letzten verbliebenen in dieser ganz erfolgreichen Everspiker-Mannschaft. Dafür, dass man seinen Kapitän verloren hat, den Trainer verloren hat, den Aufstiegstrainer, den Wundermacher fast schon, und dann auch noch die besten Talente verloren hat, sind sechs Punkte jetzt schon mal sehr gut zum Auftakt. Vermutlich werden sie nicht wieder Relegation spielen. Aber das hat schon mal jetzt ein bisschen Hoffnung gemacht, dass man auf jeden Fall vielleicht so unbedarfte Beobachter wie mich dann lügen strafen kann, dass man auch in diesem Jahr nicht gegen den Abstieg spielen wird. Aber auch da ist vielleicht für einen Urteil noch zu früh. Aber man hat trotzdem klug gemacht. Und ich glaube einfach, dass man in vielen Spielen weiterhin solide bis unangenehm für die Gegner sein wird. Und dann reicht es in der 2. Liga ja oftmals schon. Wenn man nach Standards noch gut ist und Tore machen kann, wie gegen den Klub, dann kann man Spiele auch gewinnen.
Du sagst es.
Also, ja. Albersberg auch von mir erstmal. So einen leichten Daumen, der kommt in der Kamera. Ganz leichter.
Ja, ich würde halt sagen, es ist halt auch einfach, also man hat halt sehr schnell diese 2. Liga verstanden. Und man muss einfach sagen, du hast gerade gesagt, das ist halt eben nicht mehr der spielerisch ansehnliche Fußball. Aber muss man auch einfach sagen, spielen sehr wenige Vereine in der 2. Liga ansehnlichen Fußball. Also das ist einfach so. Also der Fußball in der 2. Liga, I'm sorry to tell you, aber der ist halt einfach nicht gut über Weitere Strecken und das ist so. Ich musste eben kurz dran denken, als du über Düsseldorf gesprochen hast, Michi, dass sie am Ende dann doch nochmal rauskommen. Sagt eben halt auch viel über die Qualität der 2. Liga aus. Das ist ein anderes Thema. Aber man muss einfach sagen, einfach jetzt zu sagen, ja ganz ehrlich, und dann spielen wir der Durchschnitt der 2. Liga. Das zu schaffen, das wäre unter einem neuen Trainer auf jeden Fall auch schon mal ein, also das schaffen andere Vereine nicht. Liebe Grüße nach Braunschweig. So, ne, also das ist halt eben, wenn man das schafft, eben auf so einem, nicht unter so ein gewisses Niveau zu fallen eben im Spiel, dann ist das vollkommen in Ordnung. Und dann, also man kann es nicht vergleichen, aber wir haben es ja irgendwann noch mal bei Sandhausen gesehen, dass die eben über viele Jahre hinweg in der 2. Liga eigentlich nicht über so ein Grundlevel gefallen sind, bis sie es dann irgendwann getan haben. Und dann, ja, jetzt auch in der Regionalliga spielen. Aber ja, also generell, und dafür ist der Standort Elbersberg, du hast es gesagt, mit Ole Bog da auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr interessant besetzt. Sie haben übrigens im DFB-Pokal knapp gegen die SSV Ulm gewonnen. Eine Partie, die man fast ein bisschen vergessen hatte, glaube ich. Es war auch irgendwie schwarz-weißes Team gegen schwarz-weißes Team. Ist immer ein bisschen wild. Aber ja, generell sind wir da, glaube ich, auch gespannt. Lasst mich da auch noch ganz kurz gucken, was die nächsten Gegner sind. Das sind Hertha BSC am Freitag. Ich habe schon mal gesagt, mal gespannt, was wir da sehen. Dann kommt Dynamo Dresden und dann geht es zu Eintracht Braunschweig. Also, ja, mal schauen, was wir von Elbersberg in dieser Saison sehen. Und dann machen wir, glaube ich, einmal ganz kurz. Wir haben jetzt schon viele Teams besprochen. Auf Platz 3 der Liga steht gerade der Karlsruher SC. Ich weiß nicht, also man hat zwei Siege, einen Unentschieden, dieses Unentschieden gegen Hertha und ja, eben sonst zuletzt der Sieg. Aber ich weiß, gegen Braunschweig eben, ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht, aber es wirkt für mich halt wie klassischer KSC-Fußball bis jetzt. Also, beim KSC wirkt es bei mir nicht so, als wäre da jetzt irgendwie so wirklich Pause zwischen gewesen. Sie machen halt, klar, es ist halt auch vieles gleich geblieben. Die machen mit Christian Aichner da gefühlt weiter, wo sie aufgehört haben. Es ist irgendwie, die werden, glaube ich, also ich habe sie ja als Ausstiegskandidat getippt, weil meine Frage ist halt, ob sie es irgendwann mal schaffen, einmal diese Stufe nochmal draufzusetzen. Aber bisher, würde ich sagen, ist ein grundsolides Level. Also, ich weiß nicht, ob es den gibt.
Das kann ich unterschreiben. Also, das, was du sagst, finde ich gerade, ist auch das, was so mit meiner ersten Einschätzung, so nach den ersten Spieltagen, resoniert, dass ich auch sage, boah, sehe ich jetzt nicht ganz oben. Also, haben sich gut verkauft, sieben Punkte. Ich habe mir die Tabelle ja auch gerade nochmal aufgemacht. Kein absoluter Top-Favorit für mich. Andererseits, wer ist das auch? Oder was heißt das auch in der Liga? Das könnte für mich so ein klassischer Fall sein, von wir sitzen hier zwei, drei Spieltage vor Schluss und es ist ähnlich eng wie letztes Jahr. Und dann könnte Karlsruhe da oben mit dabei sein. Ähnlich wie Darmstadt, über die wir vielleicht auch gleich zwei, drei Sätze noch verlieren. Aber wären jetzt keine Clubs, auf die ich wetten würde, würde ich aber ehrlicherweise auch wieder bei kaum einem Verein gehen. So wie sich das gestaltet, auch jetzt nach den ersten Spieltagen noch weniger. Deshalb ja so ein bisschen eine Wundertüte vielleicht an der ein oder anderen Stelle, was nach oben oder vielleicht auch nach unten da noch kommen kann. Aber ich glaube, erst mal kann man da sowohl wenn man Karlsruhe oder auch Darmstadt-Fan ist, erst mal sich entspannt irgendwie auf die Schultern klopfen, glaube ich. Und man ist oben dabei. Und das ist ja schon mal so nach drei Spieltagen das, was einen beruhigt, was ein gutes Gefühl gibt. Und dann schauen wir einfach mal, wie es läuft mit den beiden Teams.
Zum KSC nur ganz kurz. Ich habe schon mal in einer der früheren Sendungen meine heimliche Liebe für Marvin Wannizek kundgetan. Da hat er verlängert. Und das ist ja auch so ein Spieler, weshalb ich den KSC auch sehr positiv sehe, weil immer wenn ich ihn spielen sehe, denke ich mir, warum spielt er nicht in der Bundesliga? Und also, dass dieser Spieler immer noch beim KSC ist, ja, er ist auch schon 32, aber er schafft es einfach konstant, den KSC besser zu machen. Und es macht jedes Mal Spaß, hinzuzuschauen und in dieser Mannschaft eine Konstante zu haben, aber auch junge Talente und dann auch aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs mit Pintu Pintu Rosa, das heißt, glaube ich, Ben Fahd. Also, das ist eine gute Mischung. Mit Simmich hat man einen weiteren Stürmer dazu geholt. Die Defensive ist, sagen wir mal, diese 2. Liga solide mit Marcel Franke und solchen Spielern. Aber das reicht auch. Also, da muss man sich auf jeden Fall keine Sorgen machen beim KSC. Und ja, auch das ist so ein Verein, da kann man sich diesen nächsten Schritt irgendwann mal erhoffen oder vielleicht muss er auch irgendwann mal kommen, weil mit dem neuen Stadion, das hat einfach jetzt, also man hat einen guten Nachwuchs, man hat ein neues Stadion gebaut, man hat einen Trainer, einen sehr guten Trainer, der auch einen Ansatz für den Fußball hat. Also da kann das schon irgendwann mal mehr kommen, aber auch da bin ich wieder getrieben von Spielen, wenn ich sie halt oft mal dann sehe. Also mindestens zweimal pro Saison sehe ich sie dann auch im Stadion. Und auch dieses Spiel, das letztes Jahr gegen Fürth, das war einfach von beiden Mannschaften wirklich schlecht. Und dann, so ein Spiel hat der KSC halt auch mal drin. Und deswegen glaube ich auch daran, dass sie um den Aufstieg mitspielen. Aber sie können da auf jeden Fall mitreden, wenn dann auch andere Mannschaften da oben mal wieder schwächeln, weil sie einfach einen guten Kader und einen guten Trainer haben. Aber das habe ich heute schon über einige gesagt. Wir müssen der Gefühl einfach acht Mannschaften aufsteigen am Ende.
Ja, ich glaube einfach, was Karlsruhe hat, ist diese, wir haben ganz, ganz am Anfang über so eine Achse gesprochen und die haben sie einfach. Und du kannst um diese Achse herum, da kannst du immer mal wieder Spieler austauschen. Aber das bleibt halt. Und dann, wie gesagt, mit Christian Eichner hast du im Prinzip so ein bisschen, weiß ich nicht, den Achsenlenker da. Und deshalb funktioniert das, glaube ich, auch ganz gut. Wie gesagt, meine große Frage ist, schaffen sie es halt wirklich mal irgendwann, diesen einen Schritt weiterzugehen? Michi, du hast da gute Punkte gemacht. Das wäre halt wirklich meine Frage. Aber sonst muss man einfach sagen, ja, sie sind halt, also wir haben es bei anderen Vereinen gesehen, z. B der FC Heidenheim, was irgendwann mal daraus entstehen kann, wenn du so eine gewisse Kontinuität im Kader auf dem Trainerposten hast, dass du dann eben irgendwann einfach diesen Vorteil hast. Und wir haben es halt schon öfter mal gesehen. Fürth hat es mal vorgemacht, Bochum hat es vorgemacht, Bielefeld hat es mal vorgemacht. Nein, aber im Sinne von, wenn du mal in so einer Saison, wo du keine klassischen Aufstiegskandidaten hast, weil die Absteiger eben nicht die ganz großen Namen sind, von denen man eben, wir haben es eben gesagt, oder es kommt auch immer wieder, die nicht klassisch direkt nach oben gehen könnten, sind das ja gerade solche Vereine, wo die Kontinuität eben herrscht, dass du es eben schaffst, da eben als Verein rauszubrechen. Aber genau, da wäre eben meine Frage, ob sie das schaffen. Frage ist da natürlich, also wir schauen erst einmal ganz kurz noch, also sie hatten eine sehr entspannte Leistung im DFB-Pokal 5-0 gegen Meuselwitz. Also da war keine Schmach irgendwie erkennbar. Das haben sie locker runtergespielt. Und da muss man sagen, wenn man sich so ein paar andere Vereine anguckt, auch wenn es keine großen Sensationen weitergehen gab, ist das ja schon durchaus ein Kompliment. Es geht jetzt Samstagabend gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf, dann nach der Länderspielpause gegen Nürnberg, sonntags gegen Kiel. Das sind eben die nächsten drei Spiele. Und dann lassen wir uns noch auf Platz 2 kurz gucken. Lisa, du hast es eben schon angesprochen, der SV Darmstadt 98, eben auch zwei Sieger, ein Unentschieden. Jetzt zuletzt eben dieses Unentschieden gegen die Hertha. Und ich glaube, Mark und ich fühlen uns ein bisschen bestätigt in unserer Aussage, dass– ich weiß, ihr konntet das allerdings nicht mehr hören– aber dass Darmstadt halt einfach so eine leichte Blackbox ist, weil du hattest dieses 4-0 gegen Bochum. Ja, dann hat man 1-0 gegen Nürnberg gewonnen, aber das war ja dann doch relativ weit weg von diesem Hurra-Wußball nach vorne, den man gegen Bochum gezeigt hat. Also der SVD-Express konnte gegen Nürnberg nicht so anrollen. Und jetzt hat man schon so– man hat direkt in den ersten drei Spieltagen so ein bisschen– das ist halt so das Darmstadt, was wir so ein bisschen erwarten. Es gibt auf jeden Fall Ausschläge nach oben, aber Darmstadt unter Kohfeldt haben immer so eine gewisse– sie haben so Schwankungen drin, die aber am Ende jetzt weder nach oben noch nach unten für großes Drama sorgen. Habe ich so immer bei Darmstadt das Gefühl.
Trainer reden ja immer gerne von Unterschiedsspielern, und wenn Isaac Liedberg da bleibt, ist er halt ein potenzieller Unterschiedsspieler. Das hat man gesehen am ersten Spieltag. Dieser Abschluss gegen Bochum war das 1-0 sogar. Ich habe vor Augen, wie er den Ball da rein hämmert. Das ist einfach wahnsinnig stark. Das kann in einer engen Liga auch. Wenn du einen Stürmer hast, der funktioniert, der dir 10 bis 15 Tore schießt, kann er auch den Unterschied in so engen Spielen nicht mehr ausmachen. Deswegen bin ich bei ihnen sehr optimistisch. Ich habe diese Black Box SV Darmstadt letztes Jahr auch gesehen. Sie haben hier 5-1 gewonnen. Man dachte, die steigen jetzt auf. Im Rückspiel war das eine der schlechtesten Fußballspiele, die ich je gesehen habe. Das kann Darmstadt beides in einer Saison schaffen. Sie können es auch innerhalb von einem Monat schaffen. Sie spielen wahnsinnig die Sterne vom Himmel. Sie spielen dann wieder so, dass man denkt, die 2. Liga muss man nicht für viel Geld als Zuschauer im Stadion anschauen. Das wird mir auch komplett unschlüssig. Aber es wird wieder eine Mannschaft sein, die wahrscheinlich Spaß macht an vielen Tagen und an manchen Tagen dann auch wieder weniger. Aber es wird nie langweilig werden, glaube ich, da am Stadion zu verfolgen.
Ich glaube, das, was du mit Black Box gerade schon so ein bisschen umschrieben hast, Eva, ist ja auch das, was man so ein bisschen zwischen erster und zweiter Spieltag zu sehen bekommen hat. Also ich war auch beeindruckt, wie man da Buchum überrollt hat, ehrlicherweise. Das war nicht das, was ich ehrlicherweise so am ersten Spieltag von beiden Teams erwartet hatte in beide Richtungen. Entsprechend war ich schon auch ein bisschen so mit der Clubbrille am zweiten Spieltag, ich will jetzt nicht sagen verängstigt, das wäre jetzt zu hoch gegriffen, aber hatte da schon Sorge, dass das das nächste Torfestival gibt. Und das Spiel lief ja dann komplett anders. Also das war wirklich am Ende ein glücklicher Sieg. Ja, am Ende fragt keiner mehr, wie hast du die Punkte gemacht und wo kommen sie her? Und hast du 1-0 gewonnen oder 4-0? Das ist ja auch Teil der Wahrheit, aber das Spiel hat mich nicht so überzeugt, dass ich jetzt sagen würde, die bleiben auf jeden Fall oben dran oder spielen mit. Ich glaube, es wird spannend, einfach zu beobachten, wie sich das entwickelt, ob Liedberg da bleibt oder nicht. Das ist natürlich auch ein großes Thema, das ihr gerade schon angerissen habt. Mein Gefühl ist, wenn ich über solche Clubs wie Karlsruhe oder Darmstadt rede, was sind so die Themen? Da ist halt relativ viel Ruhe drin. Also das ist das, was ich an Clubs ganz toll finde. Klar, die wollen gerne aufsteigen. Klar, die wollen gerne auch mal wieder in die 1. Liga. Für Darmstadt ist es auch noch nicht so lange her, ohne dass ich jetzt das komplett im Kopf hätte, mit den Jahreszahlen ganz schlimm, aber ist noch nicht so lange her. Aber das ist einfach ein anderes Umfeld. Und ich weiß, ein schwieriges Umfeld und so ein klassisches Thema bei Traditionsclubs. Aber da gucke ich dann immer so ein bisschen neidisch, zum Beispiel nach Karlsruhe oder nach Darmstadt, wo man sich jetzt, glaube ich, freut, dass man oben dabei ist, wo man jetzt aber auch keine überzogenen Erwartungen hat, dass man jetzt aufsteigen muss. Weil so große Teams, wie der HSV oder wie der FC Köln, nicht mehr in der Liga sind. Was es, glaube ich, auch einfacher macht an der ein oder anderen Stelle, dass einfach da ein bisschen mehr Ruhe drin ist. Es ist weder den Mega-Hype gibt nach einem Spiel, dass man eben so hoch gewinnt wie gegen Bochum oder auch mal nach einem Unentschieden oder nach einer Niederlage, dass es nicht ganz so tief dann ins Tal direkt runtergeht.
Ich glaube, Karlsruhe-Fans sind sehr froh, dass du sie als Ruhestelle kennst.
Kommt ein bisschen, ich weiß auch schon, wir hatten ja Podcasts, wo wir über die Situation von Karlsruhe, aber ich nehme die, das letzte halbe, dreiviertel Jahr als super entspannt war. Vielleicht habe ich auch die großen Themen versäumt, aber das hat sich für mich, finde ich, deutlich, deutlich gelegt, was es so im Verein, ehrlicherweise, an Themen gibt.
Ja, also natürlich bleibt das ganz, ganz große Thema, bleibt weiterhin natürlich dieses Rundums-Fan-Projekt, Karlsruhe. Also ich glaube, das war ja das große Thema neben dem Platz, sicherlich. Und ja, da, wo Karlsruhe natürlich auch, vor allem die Fans sind natürlich auch immer sehr, sehr lautstark, weiter hingegen protestiert bzw. im Namen des Fanprojekts natürlich auch lautstark, was unternimmt. Aber generell, also ich glaube, einmal noch zu Liedberg bei Darmstadt, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, wurde eben nach dem Spiel gesagt, dass bis auf Riedel, der aber ja eh schon nicht im Kader stand und ich glaube zu Espanyol, Barcelona wechselt, niemand mehr den Verein verlassen soll. Also das war die offizielle Aussage. Ja, wir können immer einen Stand jetzt hinterher schieben. Wir wissen, wie der Fußball funktioniert. Aber das war jetzt so die letzte Aussage. Und dann ist es natürlich wirklich ein absolutes Faustpfand. Wir werden da in zwei Wochen nochmal drauf gucken und schauen, ob wir da Recht behalten hatten. Aber sicherlich, das wäre sonst ein Gewinn für den SVD. Aber wie gesagt, also ich glaube, ich bleibe dabei. Es liegt bei mir nicht am Kader, warum ich bei Darmstadt eben diese Schwingung sehe, sondern einfach an Florian Kohfeldt. Und daran bleibe ich auch, dass ich da manchmal nicht so ganz weiß, was denn jetzt seine Idee vom Fußball spielen ist, was die man so richtig durchgehend sieht. Das ist, glaube ich, mein Hauptproblem, wo ich dann deshalb sage, okay, ich weiß nicht klar, wo ich sie einordnen soll. Dann lasst uns doch noch als allerletztes, diese Folge ist schon wieder länger geworden als geplant, wer hätte es ahnen können, auf Hannover 96 gucken. Die haben den perfekten Saisonstart aller Teams hingelegt, drei Siege in drei Spielen. Wir blenden jetzt einfach mal ganz vorsichtig das DFB-Pokalspiel gegen Energie Cottbus aus. Aber man muss auch da sagen, in Hannover rechnet man mit diesem Erstrunden meistens aus. Genau, und es gab ein durchaus unterhaltsames 3 zu 1 gegen den 1. FC Magdeburg, das Tits-Derby könnte man so sagen. Man muss aber auch sagen, ja, durchaus deutlicher Spielstand, aber ich finde, Magdeburg hat über weite Strecken durchaus dazu beigetragen, dass man dieses Fußballspiel sehr, sehr gut angucken konnte. Aber man muss einfach sagen, Hannover hat sehr früh in der Saison einfach, ja, die können ihre individuelle Klasse und ihre Effizienz vom Tor einfach gnadenlos gut ausspielen, auf jeden Fall in den Ligaspielen. Kaelmann als Joker auch wieder getroffen, Bundu war wieder dabei, der ist zwar noch nicht so torgefällig, wie er gerne wäre, aber also man sieht dann auch schon, warum ein Zweitligist ihn sich leisten konnte am Ende des Tages. Aber er ist einfach ein unfassbar wichtiges spielerisches Element. Man muss wirklich sagen, also Stand jetzt, nach drei Ligaspieltagen ist Hits voll und ganz bei Hannover 96 angekommen. Michi, wie stehst du dazu?
Ja, würde man sagen, die heißeste Mannschaft der Liga. Nicht nur aufgrund dieser neuen Punkte, sondern auch wenn man es anschaut. Und das ist dann schon überraschend. Letzter Fettbezug in dieser Folge dazu. Auch da hat man einen großen Unbruch gemacht. Die Zahlen sind ähnlich. Also wenn ich richtig gezählt habe, 12 Abgänge, 15 Zugänge bei Hannover. Aber halt auch nicht Zugänge, die allesamt irgendwie schon mal die 2. Liga kennen, wie das ja Expertinnen und Experten gerne sagen, sondern die aus– ich habe es mir aufgeschrieben– Frankreich, Polen, England, Südafrika, Japan, Schottland kamen, da dann schon so schnell mit einem neuen Trainer, mit einem neuen Trainerteam eine Mannschaft zusammenzubauen, die 9 Punkte holt, die guten Fußball spielt, die auch nicht glücklich 3-1 gewonnen hat, sondern auch, wenn man die Daten anschaut, dass auch vollkommen verdient war, dass man da 3 Tore gemacht hat. Die natürlich haben auch 3 Neuzugänge dann gleich getroffen. Gut, bei so vielen ist dies ja bescheid. Dann ist es einfacher, wenn jeder Spieler neu ist, dann treffen wir auch nur neue Spieler. Aber das sieht einfach sehr gut aus. Auch da ist ja das Umfeld, wenn man Hannover hätte, also war ja lange ein Bundesligastandort, ist es so immer noch, wenn man dort im Starten ist. Das finde ich auch. Die Stadt ist eine große Stadt. Da ist vieles dafür da, um wieder einen Bundesligaufstieg zu schaffen. Vielleicht hat man mit Christian Titz genau den Trainer jetzt geholt, der dann da die hohen Anschwäche, die man sich ja auch hat, für einen guten Fußball verbinden kann mit einem guten Kader. Man ist immer noch finanziell gut aufgestellt. Da muss man jetzt auch nicht so viel sparen. Insofern finde ich schon mal sehr, sehr gut, was da passiert. Ich bin überrascht, wie gut das dann auch aussehen kann nach so einem Neustart, schon nach drei Spielen. Wie gesagt, ich finde das ist fast die größte Leistung neben der neuen Punkt, dass man so viele verschiedene Spieler aus so vielen verschiedenen Ligen, die aus unterschiedlichen Niveaus kommen, auch mit verschiedenen Sprachen, dass man die so schnell vereinen kann. Das ist schon richtig stark.
Da muss ich gestehen, das hätte ich ehrlicherweise auch nicht erwartet und war das, was mich überrascht hat. Ich weiß noch, wie ich meine Tipps für die Auf- und Absteiger, abgegeben habe, dass ich über eine Datenanalyse vom Global Soccer Network gestolpert bin. Ich habe mir den Titel hier noch mal aufgeschrieben, wie TILZ 96 zum Aufstieg führt auf datenbasierte Analyse. Ich war auch schon so, okay, verstehe ich, was mir da alles erklärt wird, aber weiß ich nicht, ob das nicht zu optimistisch ist, weil Daten sind das eine und die Menschen dahinter, ein neues Team aufzubauen, ein Teamgefüge aufzubauen, auch einfach einen Fußball spielen zu lassen, der dann passt und der das System des Trainers verkörpert. Das hätte ich ehrlicherweise schon gar nicht in der kurzen Zeit nicht erwartet. Deswegen, ich habe Hannover nicht getippt. Jetzt ärgere ich mich so ein bisschen, weil man hätte es vielleicht sehen können, wenn man sich die Daten so tief angeguckt hat. Du hattest ja auch vorhin schon gesagt, Eva, 2. Liga-Fußball ist selten schön und macht selten Spaß. Hannover habe ich mir jetzt echt gerne die letzten Spieltage angeguckt, weil die einfach Fußball spielen. Die sind mutig, die haben viel Ballbesitz, die stehen aber auch hinten total stabil. Das hat wirklich Spaß gemacht, muss ich sagen. Deshalb würde ich da auch mitgehen bei Sind ein heißes Eisen. Ich weiß nicht, wer sie getippt hat aus unserer Runde. Da müsste ich vielleicht nochmal im Großen... Ah, da würde ich vielleicht sagen Glückwunsch. Nach den ersten drei Spieltagen würde ich da jetzt auch nochmal umschwenken, weil wirklich ganz, ganz viel schon klappt. Ich finde, man hat auch so prominente Abgänge, finde ich. So Trezoldi habe ich jetzt nicht groß vermisst, die ersten Spiele über. Also, das war ja auch so ein bisschen das eine oder andere, so wie verstärkt man sich und ja, wer fehlt denn dann da und wie wird es? Also, da muss ich echt sagen, hätte ich nicht erwartet, hat mich total überrascht, dass das direkt so funktioniert, wie es funktioniert. Also, gut ab an den ersten drei Spieltagen in Richtung Hannover.
Meine Frage wäre jetzt eben noch, wie schaffen sie es denn? Also, natürlich hast du nicht 1 zu 1 Energie Cottbus in der 2. Liga, aber man muss einfach da sagen, also Cottbus hat dann schon gezeigt, womit Hannover Probleme haben könnte, wenn sie eben, ja klar, Ballbesitzfußball ist jetzt Fußball, aber halt gegen Teams, die halt auch wirklich tief stehen und dann aber eine Körperlichkeit mitbringen, die halt so, also, na, Hannover hatte die besseren Chancen, aber sie haben ein Tor halt eben nicht gemacht. Und gleichzeitig dann halt doch einmal zu anfällig, sind über die Außen nicht richtig durchgekommen. Und da sieht man dann schon, dass es da vielleicht doch ein, zwei Punkte gibt, wo du 96 eben unter Teams auch knacken kannst. Jetzt als nächstes eben gegen Kiel auswärts, zu Hause gegen die Hertha und auswärts gegen Dynamo Dresden. Und auf das Spiel, wie gesagt, bin ich auch sehr, sehr gespannt, was wir da dann sehen. Also weil, wenn Dresden so auftritt wie gegen Bielefeld und dann eben vielleicht auch nicht so viele Balle haben will und Hannover muss das Spiel machen, da bin ich schon durchaus gespannt, was wir da von 96 sehen. Aber man muss schon einfach sagen, also ich glaube, Hannover-Fans trauen dem Raten da auch noch nicht so ganz, weil sie einfach, glaube ich, auch viel enttäuscht worden sind die letzten Jahre. Aber ich muss sagen, es scheint wirklich per se zu passen. Markus Mann hat da gute Arbeit geleistet. Der hat dann natürlich auch gewisse Sicherheiten. Bei Hannover natürlich nie Ruhe neben dem Platz, auch das wissen wir alle. Da gibt es, glaube ich, jetzt auch gerade die Abstimmung, wie die neuen Stadionsitze farblich gestaltet werden sollen, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe. Also auch sehr wild. Aber ich meine, gut, wir alle kennen die von Fortuna Düsseldorf. Ich würde das auch die Fans entscheiden lassen wollen, wie das aussieht. Aber gut, generell muss man aber echt sagen, Hannover 96 macht Spaß. Hannover erfüllt die Vorstellung von vielen. Also wie gesagt, ich glaube, es war eben, Lisa, du hast es, was viele Leute tatsächlich beschäftigt hat. Also schafft es Tiet sofort, eben diesen großen Umbruch zu verarbeiten. Und Stand jetzt muss man sagen, tut er. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie jedes Spiel bis zum Ende der Saison gewinnen werden. Aber man muss ja sagen, vielleicht dahin gehen doch gar nicht mal so schlecht, dass sie aus dem Pokal raus sind. Das heißt, Belastungssteuerung etc. PP können sie sich vollends auf die 2. Liga verlassen. Und das ist sicherlich keine nur schlechte Idee für Hannover.
Und wenn es einen Trainer gibt, dem man zutraut, einen tiefstehenden Gegner gut zu bespielen, dann ja wohl Christian Titz, der das in Magdeburg ein paar Exelos gezeigt hat, dass man auch mit 65 Prozent beibeisetzt. Wenn die Automatismen klappen, wenn man sich besser kennt, dann auch. Es war ein Gegnerbespiel und klar, gegen Kiel und Hertha werden es jetzt auch nicht immer nur den Ball haben, es müssen auch zwei Mannschaften, die spielen wollen. Wie du sagst, dann wird es gegen Dresden vielleicht spannender, aber es sind halt auch noch drei Wochen mit einer Länderspielpause dazwischen. Also in diesen drei Wochen kann man schon noch, jetzt fast vier, aber drei Spiele. Also da kann man schon auch einiges noch einstudieren.
Ja, und es zeigt natürlich...
Wir müssen noch mal eine These untermauern, dass hier.
Naja, und man muss auch einfach sagen, also Hannover zeigt halt, wie wichtig es ist, wenn ein Kader früh steht. Und dann kann es fast sogar, ich sag mal in Anführungszeichen, egal sein, wie viel Umbruch es gab. Weil das haben sie jetzt einfach, sie konnten einfach anfangs an mit gefühlt 80 Prozent der 11, die jetzt auf dem Platz steht, eben arbeiten. Und das ist einfach ein Unterschied. Und ich glaube, ja, mit Hannover werden wir noch viel Spaß haben. Ich würde jetzt aber sagen, wir hatten jetzt genug Spaß. Vielen Dank, dass ihr euch beide doch so lange Zeit genommen habt. Es war die erste Folge in diesem neuen Format. Ich glaube, wir können uns sicher sein, wir werden nicht immer über alle Vereine so viel sprechen, aber wir dachten, wir nehmen das jetzt doch mal alles so ein bisschen mit rein, weil es eben viele Storys zu erzählen gibt an die Vereine, die wir jetzt nicht besprochen haben, oder an die Fans dieser Vereine. Seid nicht böse, eure Vereine kommen sicherlich in der nächsten Folge wieder dran. Es ist vielleicht auch ab und zu ein Kompliment, wenn man noch nicht über sie spricht. Und sonst natürlich der Hinweis noch mal. Gestern ist die Folge zum ersten Spieltag, der Bundesligaspieltag der Männer erschien, mit Petra Neher und Max Eichinger. Da könnt ihr auch noch gerne reinhören, wenn ihr es noch nicht gemacht habt. Und sonst hören wir uns in zwei Wochen wieder. Da bin ich auch wieder hier. Und Marc hört ihr dann irgendwann Mitte September wieder. Versprochen. Und dann, wie gesagt, bedanke ich mich ganz, ganz herzlich bei Lisa Höfer. Danke, dass du dabei warst. Mal wieder.
Vielen, vielen Dank. Ich freue mich total, dass es geklappt hat. Das nächste Mal vielleicht mit ein paar positiveren Clubgeschichten. Aber wir schauen, was kommt.
Und lieben Dank natürlich auch an Michi Fischer, ausnahmsweise mal hier, ohne über die Spielvereinigung viel zu sprechen. Danke, Michi.
Ganz ohne ging es ja nicht. Aber ich habe mich bemüht, möglichst wenig darüber zu sprechen. Danke für die Einladung. Hat mir immer sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Ja, und sagt gerne, was ihr von dieser Folge gehalten habt. Und bis bald. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank.
Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.